Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burn.
It's time for the Monday morning podcast for Monday.
Uh,
what the hell was it?
October 12,
2015 what's going on?
How are you?
I'm,
I'm recording this Sunday because as you're listening to this,
um,
unless I posted tonight,
Oh,
who's kidding,
who my podcasts guide posted cause I don't know how to do it.
Um,
I'll actually,
I got some acting work,
uh,
Monday and Tuesday.
So it was always,
I never tell you what the hell I'm doing because you know,
you can get edited out and then you look like an asshole.
Like you say,
hey everybody,
look for me.
I'll be that guy in that thing.
And then all of a sudden you're not in it.
And then he goes,
Hey,
I thought you were going to be a nut,
you know,
laughing my ass off.
Epic fail actor Balding,
redheaded Con,
you know,
I got to deal with that all day.
So I usually don't say anything,
but I'm mean,
I'm excited.
It's going to be fun.
It's funny shit.
And,
uh,
so that's why I got to do over the next couple of days.
But,
um,
so it's football Sunday,
I'm recording this right,
is the,
uh,
the Patriots and cowboys game just ended,
I'm not going to gloat.
Um,
I know that that was a banged up,
a cowboy stem and come on,
I think the last play of the game when you guys,
your receiver beat our quarterback and the ball still sailed like eight feet
over.
His fucking,
I felt bad for them was at number 83.
I don't know who he is.
So I know he needs those stats.
They all need the stats.
That's how they make their money.
You know,
the end of the season when they're,
they're,
they're uh,
they're sports.
Uh,
agent comes in,
hey,
you'll need to the guy we now for nothing.
And the guy,
uh,
you had fucking 17 touchdowns.
So
after 16,
that means he fucking makes an extra 400 grand.
So with this guy comes up one short,
you think he's not going to be thinking about that.
You know,
when they have the cowboys Christmas party and they don't make the playoffs,
you don't think 83 is going to be staring at that fucking,
uh,
that radio contest winner that they had a quarterback.
I shouldn't talk shit about him,
you know,
I don't know anything about him either.
But um,
that play really made me laugh because after the ball goes over 83,
his head,
I think that's his number,
right?
You see him yelling at the corner and the corner is kind of laughing back at him
and you know,
he was going like,
I fucking beat you again.
I should've had fucking 150 yards on you.
If this guy could fucking throw it to me and the other guy doesn't give a shit
cause he knows in the end,
right.
It's just going to show up on the stat sheet.
Who gives a shit?
So,
uh,
anyways,
so you know,
I felt bad for the cowboys.
You know what I mean?
Snakebit it just fucking snake pit and they looked like they were going to be
good.
Tony Romo gets heart bought it out to Donna.
All that bullshit.
You know,
but,
uh,
I do think on one level it was a justice by the football gods that the patriots,
who some people were suggesting,
you know,
if the Brady suspension went through,
could have been oh,
and four one and three,
two and two that were actually for now,
I think that that means the football gods know that Tom Brady did not cheat.
Okay.
Oh,
you guys can fucking roll your eyes and shake your heads all you want.
You know what the greatest thing about it is,
is I can't hear you right now.
Do you ever think about that?
I can't hear you,
but you can hear me.
So you,
you have to listen to this shit.
All right?
You don't have to,
but I know if you're listening to this shit right now,
you're probably doing something you don't want to be doing and you need to be
distracted.
So all you can do is sit there and hope that maybe it's going to get better or
you could fast forward through it.
Cause I'm gonna tell you right now,
I'm going to talk about this for another couple,
two or three minutes.
He might want to jump ahead.
You know,
if you're a fucking,
uh,
with a big crybaby,
but if you're a cult said,
you know,
it's such Saint Andrew luck his heart.
Man.
I want to go in there and I want the Patriots.
That guy just said,
I want to go in there and fuck somebody at the door.
Hold on a second.
Hold on.
Hang on.
All right,
I'm back.
Clean up.
Get over there.
Laid out.
This is what happens when you got a crazy pitbull.
You gotta make sure you wait,
wait,
wait.
You got to close all the doors so you don't need anyone
lay down.
All right.
Sorry.
Sorry,
I'm back.
Dogs.
Crazy man.
Dog.
Dog is awesome.
But uh,
she's only awesome till like seven people on everybody else.
Look at right now.
She's sitting in the bed or bed with their ears up.
You know what I mean?
Listening intently.
Totally locked in that Terry,
your gene,
cleo still not looking.
Let's see a lot.
I have to say her name.
Cleo.
Cleo,
There we go.
Relax.
Okay,
stand down.
Um,
anyways,
I like how he said I want to go in there,
I want to go into Indianapolis and I want to sit there and you know,
fucking sausage kig cause I watched athletes play at a professional level.
No,
I was saying I want to,
uh,
I want to,
I wanted to see the patriots,
you know,
go in and play the colts at full fucking strength if we go on next week.
Okay.
And if we win,
God willing,
you know,
Andrew Luck's not 100%,
so I'm not going to gloat about that when I hate when fucking people do that
shit.
You know what I mean?
So,
uh,
but what a lot of leak,
there was so many games,
those one o'clock games and I just thought were,
were over,
you know,
all right.
Browns are getting their ass kicked.
Seattle's killing fucking Cincinnati.
There was one other one in there.
Um,
Cincinnati came back,
the browns came back.
Who else came back?
There was like three fucking games in the beginning.
Ah,
Christ,
I can't,
all the bills,
the bills ended up coming back to,
I was watching that game.
Um,
you know,
tightens a young,
they don't not have close out a team yet,
but,
uh,
I'm always watching Rex Ryan.
Man,
I liked the way that guy coaches,
and it's funny to see him lose.
Nobody takes off a fucking headset when he loses.
Like Kim,
he's always good for a couple of courtesies.
Fucking shitty tests,
test the thing off.
But um,
yeah,
so anyways,
I actually totally got off track.
So I was talking about like,
I literally think that,
uh,
not to make excuses for,
how dumb I am,
but there I
really think there's something wrong with the way my brain is wired.
The way I,
when I visually look at something and try and process it.
And this fucking flyer it had,
it didn't have,
uh,
you know,
the thing was the show was down at the shrine auditorium or something like that,
which I found out led Zepplin actually played at.
Um,
I was not in that theater,
obviously
that is in the,
I was at basically the hallway area that led to the arena that,
uh,
the theater I should say,
that,
um,
that zipline played in.
And,
um,
anyways,
but I noticed the flyer and completely fucked me up because at the,
there was shows from basically like three in the afternoon to 12 midnight.
So when they listed the shows,
for some reason they started at 12 midnight and they went backwards.
And then the block that I was in was basically Largo comics with um,
Veruca salts.
Band was actually the band that you got to play with,
which is fucking awesome.
Right?
And just the way they had it,
like instead of going down,
you know,
I can't even explain it.
I mean,
once you go fucking like five,
six,
seven,
eight,
you wouldn't go 1211.
Right.
But if I had any sort of like learning visual,
a billability,
I would've just looked at it like,
I just look at something like that and I just go like this.
When I see all of that shit,
it just,
my brain just goes like,
ah,
I can't even fucking see it totally turns my brain to mush.
And all I saw was Largo.
So my dumb ass drives to Largo.
Now obviously most of you don't live out here.
So Largo is basically without traffic is about 20,
25 minutes away from the shrine auditorium.
So there's always traffic here.
So it was a colossal fuck up on my part.
And um,
and of course I didn't bring the,
I had the parking passes in the wristband,
I had all of that laid out ready to go and my brain kept saying for days and
days and days,
go and make sure you have that,
make sure you have that.
And as I was getting ready to leave,
I saw it on the desk.
I'm like,
Oh yeah,
that thing,
that thing.
And then I fucking go and get my keys and,
and I walk out the door without the parking pass,
without the wristband driving to Largo,
the exact opposite direction when I'm supposed to go to the other fucking place.
It was a,
a,
an absolute shit show.
And I really,
on the way over,
um,
I can't bring myself to say,
because I've always said that it's just an excuse,
but I would just say there's something fucked up with the way my brain is wired.
Cause my whole life it's just like I,
it's like I don't think I'm dumb,
but I continued to do dumb shit.
So the end of the day,
right,
it's the results that's like say I'm a good quarterback but I keep losing the
game.
Right?
So at the end of the day,
yeah,
you suck as a quarterback.
So I would love to hear,
you know,
considering I'm not a doctor,
obviously,
obviously I'd like to hear your guys' analysis cause that's what this whole
fucking Internet thing is about.
The Internet is about people who have absolutely zero qualification,
just Shiming in what their opinion just going on and fuck this,
what this podcast is.
I'm looked up any of that.
I don't fucking know anything.
Right?
So when he was,
so I drive over to the,
um,
the venue and uh,
it's fucking gigantic place.
It's one of those places they bring into it.
You don't even know what it looks like.
It's so fucking big.
I came in from like the parking structure and uh,
I get in and I'm walking by and as the open area that I'm going to be on that
stage.
And then I walk by and then I go by the theater.
Then evidently led Zeppelin played at,
and a Reggie watts is on stage.
Of course crushing it.
I went upstairs,
I met the people in the band and then they basically just fucking ran through if
you want blood.
And I sat there air drumming and that's one of those songs that fades out.
So the big thing was like,
all right,
how the fuck are we going to end this song?
Um,
and then we're like,
all right,
let's do it.
So then when I came back downstairs,
I'm walking by that it was this weird thing where you walked behind the theater
where the guy was on state.
I can't even explain it.
Yeah.
Okay.
I can't even explain it.
So this time when I go down,
Reggie is finishing up.
I walk in,
go on into this hall fucking area.
And then we're in the,
the basically the giant open area that looks,
it looks like a giant mall after the apocalypse.
There was an upper deck,
but there was no stores and it wasn't really well lit.
And,
um,
so anyways,
the show starts Greg Behr and Kilz tick the towers killing.
So I'm thinking everybody's killing.
I gotta get my shit together.
So when I walked into the other area,
um,
to get my head together,
I looked in super,
Dave Osborne was on stage where Reggie was just on stage and for guys my age and
older,
you remember him from that show.
Bizarre.
And I'm definitely going to work.
I got to put up some clips,
hopefully I'll fucking remember.
I would say I haven't to put up some clips and then I taught for another 50
minutes.
I forget it.
But uh,
he was on stage and um,
I would've loved to have met that guy.
That guy used to fucking kill me when I was a kid.
And,
um,
but anyways,
Jesus,
Bill,
get to the fucking point here.
So I go on stage,
I do my thing and I'm
a tell my jokes or whatever and now I'm to go back and go play the fucking
drums.
You know,
when you sit down on somebody else's kid,
it's like driving somebody else's car.
The chairs either to fucking closest stairwell,
not the high hat and all that stuff.
So I sit down,
we start fucking playing.
I fuck it up from the very beginning.
Uh,
not in a bad way.
I'm just,
I'm just not playing it the way it is on the album.
And I can see the guitar play looking at me like,
dude,
what the fuck?
He didn't do that upstairs.
So I continued doing the same mistake but on time.
So you know,
nobody fucking notices.
But he's looking at me like,
wow,
is this going to be a train wreck?
There were,
at least I felt he was,
it's probably my own insecurity.
And then we start to play and I can't hear anything.
I couldn't even hear the bass drum.
And it was like,
wow,
this is,
I didn't realize that musicians have to deal with this shit.
So it was Kinda cool.
So I'm literally can almost hear one of the guitarists and I'm watching his foot
and I just started humming the song in my head.
I'm just doing that.
It's grim and know then as humans do what?
I'm just back there humming this fucking song.
But it was great.
They kept turning around looking at me when we were going into the verse.
So it ended up going,
uh,
going great.
But the highlight of it other than getting to play with for Lucas Salt,
which is the fucking shit,
um,
they totally rocked the whole fucking night.
Right.
I was a at one point I looked up at the crowd cause that was one of my goals.
Just like with stand up.
Like I had to be like I'm taking the Mick out of the mic,
stand on baby,
step in this thing with every once in a while playing out playing drums.
Right.
I actually was trying to look up at the crowd more.
So at one point I'm looking up to the crowd is I'm humming the song cause I
can't,
I can barely hear people.
Um,
I saw this woman in the crowd and she was standing there.
She wasn't moving at all,
wasn't tapping your toes,
wasn't fucking nodding her head,
nothing.
And she had this blank stare and,
but she wasn't looking at anybody.
She was just sort of daydreaming,
standing right in the front.
She was like the poster child for like being completely disconnected to anything
that was going on stage.
And when I saw her,
the old me that would've crushed me because I was so self conscious about my
playing.
But when I saw her,
I actually looked down.
I just looked down and I started laughing.
And,
uh,
I didn't think about it until I was driving away.
When I was critiquing the shit out of everything I did,
I was actually driving away and I took that.
That was my victory on that one,
was that,
uh,
she clearly was not into it and it didn't rattle me.
It actually made me laugh and I was able to find the humor in that.
And I was talking to another comic about it and I,
I feel like,
uh,
that's the difference between a performer that stays doing it.
And somebody who just after a while just quits.
And I'm not saying one person is better than another,
but in order to fucking do any sort performing,
you have to find the humor in bombing or you're fucked.
You have to be able to look at somebody is you're trying,
you're fucking hardest.
And they're just sitting there like,
I mean,
dude,
she was thinking about next Wednesday or some shit or something from our
childhood,
like she was that far
the day.
Jayman it was fucking brutal.
And you've gotta be able to look at that and just be like,
what I'm doing,
right.
Yeah.
Now made her do that.
You know,
like that's how bad I am right now.
So whatever I was able to shake it off,
you know,
it's,
hopefully the cowboys will be able to shake off today's loss right there.
Did I bring it back?
Speaking of losing,
uh,
my Boston Bruins,
my beloved,
hey,
we go bro.
It's,
here we go.
Our,
um,
they're all in too now we,
we got shellacked by Winnipeg.
We played good for a period and a half,
you know,
but then again,
the game is three periods,
but whatever,
it's a brand new fucking team.
We got rid of everybody.
They got to figure out how they're going to Joe.
Right.
So I'm not freaking out yet and I don't have any,
you know,
ridiculous expectations,
especially,
uh,
our coach Clo,
Julian and I already had one guy go after we lost a Montreal.
He goes,
you know,
they,
uh,
is it time to shorten up the leash,
Upload Julian?
It's like,
why?
Why would you do that?
Does he suddenly not?
No,
no.
Understand the game of hockey.
Why would you blame the fact that they're all in to,
on him?
This guy coached the team when he had the players to winning a fucking Stanley
Cup.
That was only four years ago.
It's not like it was 40 years ago.
The game hasn't passed.
The dude.
Bye.
Okay.
In that time we lost Tyler Sagan,
Johnny boy chuck.
Okay.
Douggie Hamilton and Lou cheats the face of our franchise.
It's a whole new fucking team.
When he had those guys.
I'm also those guys.
Doug,
he was on the 2011 team yet.
I can't remember.
He won a cup.
So I don't think,
you know,
if you're going to bitch when they're trying to Redo the whole fucking team
after two losses,
if you got to bitch about anybody,
you got to bitch about our new GM,
dawn Sweeney.
That's the guy who should take,
be taken the heat,
not the fucking coach,
you know,
would say shit like that.
Dan Shaughnessy,
Dan Shaughnessy would say shit like that because the man doesn't watch hockey.
So anyways,
I actually saw a lot of positives in the,
um,
uh,
yet another loss,
um,
to the Canadians to hate it.
Canadians,
um,
so many new,
I mean I didn't get to watch the Winnipeg game,
but Joe Barton,
nick from puck off podcast told me that a Winnipeg is a force and that there is
no fucking shame in losing to them.
Then,
you know,
they're loaded,
which is fucking annoying to me.
It's like,
well,
how are they loaded?
How are they under the salary cap?
And they're fucking loaded.
I don't know,
just how to think.
But he got more money than us.
They're in fucking Winnipeg.
I've been to Winnipeg.
All right.
I don't know what the fuck you do out there,
but somehow they got more money than us.
Why?
Cause they're always digging a new fucking canal for a mall because it's too
cold to be outside.
Maybe.
Is that what it is?
I don't fucking know.
But anyways,
I saw some,
uh,
I saw some positive shit.
Jesus Christ.
We had like seven penalties and to all you Canadian fans out there,
I'll admit we were guilty of all of them.
I didn't have a problem with any of the calls.
Uh,
even the five minute one that spoke to took right the game,
the game misconduct.
Uh,
I didn't have a problem with any of those carry price looked fucking great.
And uh,
but you know,
other than the first penalty kill,
which we looked like a beer league team,
um,
you know,
we killed off all those,
including the five minute major at one point.
We would when,
uh,
what's his face?
Uh,
um,
good Lord.
Bill,
what is wrong with your brain right now?
Brian Marshawn.
Jesus Christ.
He took a penalty.
We actually had a five on three.
They had a five on three for a minute.
We still killed that.
We had a goal called back.
I didn't have a problem with that either.
We will literally laying on the dude's mask,
but uh,
I don't know.
I think we were bad.
We will competitive.
I'll give us that.
So I'm sticking it out.
I'm watching every game.
We got Tampa Bay next.
We'll probably lose to that one.
You know,
I dunno
is Bart.
Nick told me we got to beat the bad teams and fucking hang in there and a,
who knows.
We've gotten rid of everybody.
I got to think that we have some salary cap,
uh,
money leftover that maybe we can pick somebody up or something.
I don't fucking know.
I don't know what they're doing,
but don't blame the fucking coach for the love of God.
We don't even have shower showers out right now.
Um,
but I liked that number.
39 kids though.
We got from the ducks that uh,
how do you say his name?
Matt Boleski or whatever he looks good.
Pasta knock is going to be great.
I think,
I know we got some shit.
Get some shit right Craig.
He's healthy.
Gray,
G,
Patrice Bergeron.
You know,
I think it will be okay.
Um,
whatever.
I'm not gonna be one of those guys that fucking bitch moans and complains there.
Right?
We did.
We did fine.
Did find those tours to games.
I'm still gonna Watch him.
You know,
it was,
if they keep playing the way that they're playing,
I'm,
I'm all right with it.
I can handle that.
As long as whatever dawn Sweeney is doing is leading towards the light.
You know,
actually my Sean took a fucking elbow to the head of the end of the game.
I think he's got a concussion that's brutal.
One of our best fucking guys.
Right?
And uh,
I don't think it was deliberate.
You never know.
But I just think the guy was so much taller than him.
He was just trying to do the contact thing.
Um,
you see this people,
this is like actually seeing both sides of it.
I did that with the Patriots.
I'm doing it with the Bruins.
Right.
I became a model sports fan right now.
You liked,
you probably don't because it's probably not as funny.
You really brought me to fucking go off and some shit.
Is that,
what,
is that what you want?
I'll tell you what I'm going to go off on.
Like I actually,
uh,
I felt bad for Mcdonald's.
Okay.
You know,
first of all,
this whole excitement that to trying to create about the fact that they're
serving breakfast all day.
I mean I might be out of the loop,
you know,
I'm an older fellow,
but nobody I know,
I know is,
has ever bitched at Mcdonald's,
doesn't serve breakfast all day.
They might bitch,
you know when you show up at 10 31,
are you still serving breakfast?
No,
I'm sorry.
You know,
and you've got a hangover and you just want one of their fucking sausage,
egg and cheese and now you've got to get like a quarter pounder.
You know something about the eggs,
you know,
you did.
I got to eat some eggs and ham,
a little bit of biscuit.
Right.
I could see that and I could see them,
hey,
from now,
now on we're going to be serving a breakfast until 11:00 AM.
That would have been fine.
But to watch these guys just cave in to their fan base and just say,
you know what?
Okay,
you know what you guys,
you win,
you win.
You can have breakfast all day long to watch them do that.
It's like watching a great artist just completely sell out.
Right.
And just start,
you know,
making songs that really meant something and connected with the to just do it.
Remember at the time of Bryan Adams put on the eyeliner and spiked up his
fucking hair and just like how it,
how did the summer is 69 guy go from this to that and well,
what happened?
This was Mcdonald's is doing right now.
They got their eyeliner on and they got their fucking hair all spiked up.
They might as well,
it's just,
you know,
when they announced that they fucking going to do breakfast all day,
they might as well have had Ronald McDonald behind two turntables.
Pretended to be like a DJ.
You know,
have a little self esteem.
Mcdonald's.
Don't fucking give it to these fucking animals.
Fuck Damn.
If you can't roll your fat ass out of bed by 10 or 10 30,
you get an a burger.
All right?
Fuck you.
Yeah.
Gotta make eggs for your all God damn day.
I'm not fucking burgers like 99 cents.
What more could we be doing for you?
Yeah.
Could we do it for you?
What more could we be doing for you?
See that?
That said fucking hiccup in my brain.
Um,
I think it's a bad move.
You don't see Wendy's doing that.
Wendy's does even serve breakfast.
They're like,
fuck you.
We make hamburgers and you know what?
This square deal with it.
Right?
Mcdonald's,
you're the dealer.
You're the pusher.
Okay?
You let the junkies come to you.
You don't start slashing prices.
Okay?
I ain't just the cake.
You,
you fucking billions and billions of served the formula fucking worst.
What are they so afraid of?
Yeah,
because I'll tell you right now,
you know what sucks Denny's.
Let's just talk breakfast food right here.
You know Danny's fucking blows.
I don't know what it is about them.
They are like,
like I hop is like the Iroc CE in Denny's is just the,
the,
you got a Camaro but it's got a v six in it.
I don't know why they serve the exact same.
The exact same film.
Have the same menu.
They just call it different shit.
Right?
It's like Mcdonald's and Mcdonald's.
Right,
but there's some bad,
I hop,
you know the,
the,
the pancakes.
Fluffier Bacon's a little more crispier.
I liked it.
Toasts better.
You know,
eggs are eggs,
whatever,
you know,
don't ever awarded scrambled eggs.
Do you want scrambled eggs?
You make them yourself.
Okay.
They just,
nobody knows how to make fucking scrambled eggs.
Nobody knows how to make oatmeal.
They know how to make oatmeal,
but they made it like nine hours ago and they just stick it in a giant Vat.
I'll give you guys a great tip on fucking when you make scrambled eggs.
All right?
When you scramble them,
you've got to scramble the shit out of him.
All right.
When I scramble eggs,
all right.
Put two or three in the bull.
Okay.
It's like a cooking show,
except he listened to it.
Right.
Um,
you fucking,
you know how the hell I even got on the subject.
How the fuck does this happen?
I'm telling you guys how to scramble eggs.
You realize how insulted you should be right now.
This is like something you'd tell a five year old.
But this is a little secret that I made scrambled eggs forever.
And you know what?
They tasted like the scrambled eggs at Denny's and I was proud.
I was like,
these are just like the ones that Denny's but I didn't realize that daddy's
absolutely sucked.
Right.
So,
um,
I'm just loving all the tweets I'm going to get.
Cause you know,
there's people out there that love Denny's and thinks ihops stinks.
I will tell you this.
Denny's tables not as sticky.
I hop has cornered the fucking market.
I mean to you,
put your elbow on that table.
If you leave it there for more than three seconds.
I mean somebody's got to get a putty knife for you not getting it off there.
Um,
so anyways,
the,
the scrambled eggs,
this is what you want to do,
right?
You put two or three in a bull,
whatever you want to fucking do.
All right?
And then you take out your fork and you start fucking scrambling them.
And what a lot of people do is they scramble them for like fucking,
you know,
1520 seconds tops.
You don't want to do that too.
Do you want to scramble them for like two minutes?
You want to get a bunch of air in there?
You want to scramble the shit out of him,
right?
I'm on a submarine and article on James Cotton one time he gave me this tip.
So this is from him.
So if you think I'm a fucking moron,
I'm going from a guy who was in godfather one and two.
All right?
And Elf,
three of the greatest fucking movies of all time as far as I'm concerned.
All right.
So anyways,
you've got to get that air in that you've got to have those bubbles going right
over the top.
You know what I mean?
Like a good milkshake.
That's what the fuck it should look like.
Meanwhile,
you got shipped Pan,
your pan is on.
Hi.
I know you guys Christ.
You got to cook the shit out of it.
Now she going to do is the second you pour it and you're going to be constantly
moving that motherfucker,
right?
You put it in right,
you got the Pan,
you've got your little fucking,
whatever you use,
right,
you olive oil,
whatever the fuck you,
I wouldn't put butter in there because you've got it on high,
right?
Whatever you spray in there,
you pay him,
whatever you,
whatever you use to deplete the ozone layer.
You get that thing on high,
right and right is whatever you put in their chest starts to seem like it's
going to start smoking.
You pour that shit in there and it goes
and then you move that fucker around like a stir fry.
You don't stop moving that thing.
Right and when it looks like it's about halfway done,
you pull the yeah,
pan off the burner and you finish it that way.
Then you take it,
you fucking dump it on and you're done.
That's it.
That was some point.
You put some sea salt in there too.
What?
However,
however you want to garnish it.
All right.
And I'm telling you that there'll be nice and fluffy.
Unlike that horse shit that they have down there at Denny's and IOP.
IOP doesn't make good scrambled eggs either.
And then you've got to get cheese in them.
You've got to get cheese.
But that's like ordering a steak and you got to put like fucking a one on it
because the guy didn't know how to cook it.
You should not have to put cheese in your fucking scrambled eggs if you know
what you're doing.
All right.
And you know what?
That's one to grow on.
They go,
how was that?
It took me fucking seven,
eight years of doing this podcast and I finally told you how to scramble a God
Damn Egg.
Um,
actually,
you know something,
the cooking it on high part and then taken it off.
I learned that from Nia.
She taught me that thing.
Jesus Christ,
we're already fucking halfway through this thing.
Let me,
uh,
let me do some of the reeds here for this week.
Had to scramble an egg point.
A fucking asshole.
Jesus,
that must,
maybe you should really,
you should really be fucking offended.
He should be at fender right now cause I'm not really even apologizing to you.
I'm just killing time while I try and find where the fuck I put the advertising.
Oh,
here we go.
Dollar Shave Club.
Everyone stop shaving within old Rey.
It's grouse.
Why are you torturing yourself with a gross old blade week after week?
Probably because you don't want to shell out 20 bucks for a pack of new ones.
Dollar Shave Club has revolutionized the way men shave.
With Dollar Shave Club.
You can shave with a fresh blade as often as you want because they deliver a
whole sleeve of amazing raises for just a couple of bucks a month.
Their razors are so for a few bucks a month,
I should say,
their razors are so good.
Millions of guys have joined.
Even the billion dollar raise raise.
A corporations are freaking out,
man.
Uh,
but instead of lowering their bloated prices,
they're trying to fool you into milking the same blade for an entire month.
And that's gross.
It really is gross.
Isn't that gross?
Cleo?
Um,
they've price gouge for long enough.
Never go back to squeezing weeks and weeks of shaves that over.
Disgusting.
Raise a rusty blade.
Join Dollar Shave club and use a fresh blade whenever you want.
It feels amazing and it's a third of the price.
Join the millions and millions.
The feds,
if you smell,
I've joined the millions of others who figured out the smarter way to join a
join dollar shave club now by going to dollar shave club.com/bird that's dollar
shave club.com/bar
dollar shave club.com/burr oh Jesus.
Here we go about oh boat boat beyond ds me undies.
No more sweaty taint booboo.
Dude,
do me undies.
Biondi
what fucking right?
I already did.
I already did that.
She says it all just went off the fucking rails.
Tate's a hard one.
Biondi is new and he's no more sweaty.
Taper due to two.
Munies we are these go buy a bucket of paint and the appear balls right into
them.
There'll be wetter.
I'm telling you my friend because you're not wearing your me undies.
You got your balls in the paints.
Oh yeah.
It's almost like they are sweaty except that purple by some fucking me undies.
Yeah.
Okay.
We all know how sexy confidence can be.
Oh my God.
He just feels like he knows six and that confidence comes from being
comfortable,
but how great can you feel if your underwear is wrinkled,
wrinkling and writing up the undies gets it and that's why they've created the
world's most comfortable underwear for a daily dose of confidence.
When you look good,
you feel great.
It's a cliche because it's true me.
Andy's understands this and that's why they designed underwear that makes you
feel and look great.
Look and feel fantastic.
Sorry.
Please include the fast shut up.
Me undies is made from modelle of fabric that's twice the softest cotton.
That's twice as soft as whatever you underwear you're wearing right now.
Beyond.
These has tons of colors and styles and the only place to get matching pairs
from men and women and the fucking ladies.
They even released a new design every month.
I wear whatever free pair that they send me and I love him.
Plus,
we all know that paying for shipping sucks.
So,
uh,
we undies has removed that from the equation.
All orders in the U S and Canada shipped for free me undies even has got a money
back guarantee.
If you don't love your first pair,
you get to keep it for free.
Well,
I don't love it.
I'm going to throw it out.
You literally have nothing to lose to sweeten the deal me undies is offering you
20% off your first orders at me,
undies.com/burr that's a special offer for just my listeners and everybody else
where they advertise.
Make sure you go to [inaudible] dot com slash bird he get 20% off your first
order and so that they know that we sent you.
All right.
One more legal zoom,
everybody.
You shouldn't have to choose a random lawyer who charges expensive hourly rates
when you need legal help,
but the legal zoom,
but the legal system is so complicated.
What other choice do you have when you need help with your business?
I want to protect your family.
Relax,
start with legal zoom.
They make it easy for more than a decade.
They've provided a way for regular people like you and me to confidently
navigate the legal system.
Legal Zooms,
not a law firm and that's how they provide such a great value.
They don't realize that you,
oh well,
yeah,
we don't even want,
we're doing.
They don't rely on charging you by the hour.
Instead you'll get transparent pricing and customer reviews so you know exactly
what you're getting upfront.
If you need help with and corporations,
LLCs,
trademarks,
last wills,
living trusts and more legal zooms.
The smart choice.
They've got the right people on hand to answer your questions and if you need
legal advice,
then network of independent attorneys.
There you go.
There's where the experts are over there and then trees can provide the straight
forward guidance you need in most states.
If anybody got that joke.
You've watched Predator when too many times.
Don't let legal hurdles become an excuse.
Go to legalzoom.com today to start building your own future.
The right way to save even more.
Enter burn the referral box at checkout.
That's legal zoom.com promo code [inaudible].
All right,
Jesus,
that was great.
Got Those right out of the way.
Got them right out of the way.
Okay,
now where am I going here?
Uh,
Jesus,
I always have like 9 million things open at the same time here.
Why do I do that to myself?
Oh,
by the way,
somebody sent me a link to some fucking music and I listened to a couple of
their songs,
but I really liked him.
I don't know how to say the name of the band.
It's Geo j I are a Gojira go Jarrod.
The Ohana.
I have no idea.
It's the name of the album is from Mars to Sirius.
And uh,
I usually don't like that music.
Would the people sing like [inaudible] wrote that death metal shit.
But these fucking guys,
ladies,
men and women,
I don't where the fuck they are.
They sound like they're a bunch of guys.
Um,
yeah,
blew me away.
The song did anyways.
It's called the heaviest matter of the universe.
Um,
I downloaded the album,
came out in 2006 so I'm a little late to the party.
Yeah.
But I'm,
I want to thank whoever sent me that,
um,
giving me the heads up cause I really enjoyed that song and I immediately went
and downloaded the entire freaking album over there.
Um,
all right.
What are we up to here?
34 minutes.
All right,
I'm going to do a couple more cleo and then I'm going to do the questions and
then we're going to get out of here,
right.
That doesn't mean you need to come over here.
All right.
Thank you.
Thank you for the kisses.
Cause don't be needy.
Get outta here.
Go over there and lay down.
Go on,
get over there cleo.
Please get over there.
Thank you.
Go on.
Lay down.
You Go,
you got your own fucking couch.
How much more could you be spoiled in order to is,
was today.
I watched like the whole,
I watched the bills game,
the browns and the Bengals game.
I was just clicking around.
We'll a little bit of the packers too.
And I had the whole house to myself and I was just laying on the couch and she
was up on the couch with me laying there like a fucking baby.
So now she wants the whole day like that,
you know what I mean?
She's a spoiled Brat.
Had you guys see the latest,
uh,
that fan duel thing where they got Tiki barber and a Ron de Barbara to NFL
players talking about it and I uh,
you know,
uh,
yeah,
just pick out your fucking day pickup,
be cash.
My favorite thing,
there was a guy on there where he,
this guy worked on Wall Street.
He's crushing it.
Pilfering from the greatest generation.
Right?
They're too dumb to know what's going on at this point.
They don't know what's going on in their portfolios.
Stealing from old people,
stealing from young people license to steal the man is on Wall Street.
There's nobody watching these cons.
Every once in a while they'd throw a celebrity chef in jail to make it look like
they're paying attention.
This guy was on fucking easy street and for some dumb reason,
according to this infomercial,
he just decides
to quit his job and try to win $1 million on fanduel.
I love that.
Like you,
you just can't try that on the weekend.
You got to sit there and stare at fucking stats.
Seven days of fucking whiskey for six days before you make you pick.
So long story short,
the guy goes out,
he's in the infomercial so you know he's not going to lose.
And you know what?
He goes out and he wins.
He wins 1 million bucks.
And you know what he does?
You know what he does?
Fuck head that he is.
True Romance.
He fucking quits his job.
I'm supposed to believe that this guy that works on Wall Street quit it.
Quit,
quit it.
Quit his fucking six figure job on Wall Street to make $1 million.
I know some of you fucking,
you know,
p odds on Wall Street are going to be like,
Ooh,
you know,
just start here.
I don't give a fuck about you there baby face to whiskers.
I don't give a fuck about you.
All right?
You sociopath,
you're gonna work your way up.
This guy was like my age and he was almost as bald as I am.
All right?
So if he's still on Wall Street,
he's making money.
All right?
And he's got a fucking,
you know a god damn ulcer in his stomach.
Okay,
so I know this guy's making money,
so whatever,
I don't even know.
I don't even know if I can work on some works on Wall Street.
What the fuck do I know?
So anyways,
he says that he quit his job after you made the million.
He quit his job,
he quit his job on Wall Street because he won $1 million on fanduel.
What's,
which after taxes?
Yeah.
Is going to be more than 50% tax bracket.
So let's say he gets to keep about 480 85 grand after he's done fucking,
you know,
pain is accounting and all the other bullshit.
You know what I mean by in his fucking wife,
the pink Cadillac or the fur coat.
Get it.
I get it.
I take it back and it's so bad,
I think,
right?
Once he's done doing all that right,
he's got like fucking 480 grand.
He quits his fucking job and now he's going to take that foreign 80 grand and
reinvest in his new business of gambling on football.
It's fucking guy is going to be homeless.
It's going to be almost with ims on call right now.
This guy is going to be destitute and fuck and he's gonna be one of the guys at
Bryant Gumbel interviews or actually one of his piano interviews.
You know what I mean?
He always sends them out.
Brian is not going on in the field anymore.
He's too old for that shit.
You know?
And then you come back and he does his followup where he has his little
clipboard,
a questions,
you know,
and the person sits down and he comes back and then he just goes like,
oh,
well,
whatever the fuck.
He says,
you know,
it was really high pitched voice when he's got that little like,
oh,
they're going to interview this fucking guy
and he's going to there.
You
want Brian interview somebody?
And he just thinks that that the dumbest fucking the planet he does.
He does not.
He waves his emotions,
not on his sleeve.
He wears a right on his fucking face.
I never understood that.
Why?
Why is it your sleep?
Nobody looks at your sleeve when you're talking.
I don't get what that means.
I've never understood it.
Nor did I ever look it up considering I got to fucking,
I got a Goddamn a laptop right here.
Why don't I look it up?
Come on window move for me.
We've got two defensemen on the Bruins right now.
Last name Mela do watch fucking Millie.
You're talking about what is fucking two on their both defense men calling and
fucking Kevin.
Same name.
Just my cousins.
Um,
okay.
Hey,
did anybody watched the gas monkey garage where they did that fucking 78 olds
cutlass?
What a fucking great car.
I'm not the biggest fan of low riders,
but uh,
those paint jobs are fucking ridiculous.
I think they look cool as shit,
but I'm just,
I like to,
I like going fast more than just fucking cruising around.
But uh,
the 78 olds cutlass man is fucking,
those were the cars man when I was a kid man.
From like the,
like the late seventies to like 85 the olds cutlass,
the,
the Chevy Monte Carlo and the Buick Regal,
they will basically all the same body style body type.
I thought that those were the best silicon and stock cars too,
right?
Harry Gant,
a skull bandits.
Cale Yarborough Dale Wall trip
right back when,
what's his face?
Uh,
uh,
Dale Earnhardt rest.
His soul used to drive the wrangler,
the blue and yellow wrangler.
He get out there and get sideways.
Right.
They all had old,
staid cutlasses.
Monte Carlos,
I think Harry Gant had the fucking uh,
yeah,
they get a grand Prix that had that fucking,
the rear window was just straight,
wasn't even trying to be aerodynamic,
just chopped it right down the back six,
we'll fucking bad ass cars man.
Those two door coops with that ridiculous fucking interior,
that totally cheesy.
Uh,
you know,
it all goes into the button,
that plush interior,
those fucking cars with his shit.
So they read did one,
you know what kills me.
The fucking gas monkey season is already over
10 episodes.
How the fuck does it go by that quick?
That was a brutal season for me.
Everybody brutal season went by in fucking two seconds and Casey left the show.
Um,
I dunno,
I wished that they'd let him do more shit like the,
I love when he did the lace top and when he was trying to do the low riders
stuff.
Um,
he was talking about how when they do,
they put so many layers of paint on it that it looks like you can actually,
after a while it creates the illusion.
You feel like you can actually reach down into it?
I'll fucking killer is that and just watching how they,
I don't know.
I'm such a fucking respect that and they did so many cool projects this year
where they try to do something different.
They did the old catty,
they did a low rider.
They got that Ford Gt.
Um,
okay.
Such a great fucking season and I then,
you know,
I don't know that that shows the best man.
It just went,
went by too fucking fast.
Now what am I going to do?
Right.
I had the same level of depression when like a fucking sports season ends.
Okay,
well they like to be there next week for the final episode of this season's gas
monkey garage.
I was like what the fuck are you talking about?
They just started probably cause I binged watched like five of them cause I was
on the road.
Whatever.
What the fuck am I talking about?
Oh,
wearing your emotions on your sleeve.
Hey guys,
I'm getting better at that.
Huh?
I usually go off on a tangent.
I never come back wearing his,
well fuck that.
Fuck his or her wearing emotions.
Typing with just my index finger on sleeve
definition.
Okay.
Meaning no origin.
That's what I want the origin origin of wearing your heart on your sleeve.
Oh,
that's how you say,
not your emotions.
Uh,
come on load please.
Advertising.
Oh look at that.
Pretty girl with if she lotions healthy looking skin starts here with user Id.
Continue our site.
That was it.
I just had a look at her.
She was nice to look at the origins of wearing your heart on your sleeve.
Okay.
All right.
Here we go.
It was during the Roman Empire that Saint Valentine is said to have left a note
to his jailers daughter.
Yeah.
Oh Jesus.
How much was she trying to fucking piss off her dad by fucking one of the
inmates.
Huh?
From your Valentine.
Uh,
before his execution on February 14th.
Today.
Thanks to Saint Valentine cards expressing one's heartfelt emotions,
Aka Valentine's,
are given to that special.
Someone to defer to the classic idiom.
It's a day to wear your heart on your sleeve.
Was there an explanation in there?
You started with a story and then you just deferred,
which completely fucked me up.
We use the phrase casually to mean exposing our true emotions,
making ourselves vulnerable and letting it all hang out.
The phrase is so pervasive that from Ringo Starr to m and M to carry under word,
those words to turn into the jewelry.
You're trying to stretch this out any longer.
This could have been one fucking paragraph.
Yeah,
wearing your heart on a sleeve.
Oh,
here we go.
But what kind of sleeve and why?
Honestly,
I swear to God I'm reading the copy and not pants.
Her legs and around your neck.
There's no clear answer.
You fucking Asshole,
but little mini you fucking Dick.
That's why you were stretching it out because if you just wrote,
I don't know,
I wouldn't have clicked on your site.
All right,
we've got to see it through people.
I'm sorry there's no clear answer,
but many legends attempt to to get at the heart of the matter.
Now you're going to go into upon FTE.
Tell me,
this is such a fucking train wreck.
I can't stop.
It may explain the sorts of the same.
The three most popular are in the Middle Ages.
Emperor Claudius to second believed unattached men,
made better soldiers.
So he did declared marriage illegal as a concession.
He encouraged temporary coupling once a year during a Roman festival honoring
Juno men drew names to determine who would be there.
Lady friend for the coming year once established the man would wear a name on
his sleeve for the rest of the festival.
Jesus Christ to the woman have any say no.
She's just a common who Janet.
Ruthie is.
Uh,
around that same time it's speculated when a night performed in a jousting match
in the king's court,
he dedicated his performance to a woman of the court by tying something of hers
like a handkerchief around his arm.
He let the court know the match would defend the honor of that woman or we can
credit Shakespeare and I'm not reading this Shakespeare,
you wanna hear me read Shakespeare where May,
okay,
I ago.
It is sure as you are a road road Rodrick Rodera ago where I,
the more I would be,
I would not be I ago.
Well,
I'm glad you cleared that up,
Billy.
This is right here.
Why I flunked all this shit and following him.
I follow,
but my dude,
fuck you.
Fuck you.
All right.
Jesus Christ.
Why don't you Jesus fucking Christ and you're not depressing.
That was that fucking attempt right there.
It's amazing.
I succeed in anything,
isn't it?
Oh,
by the way,
just stay doing this 20 year retrospective on Oj,
the Oj Simpson trial.
It was funny and they said the exact same shit that they said 20 years ago,
how polarizing it was and how white people saw it one way and how black people
saw it in another way.
Now obviously I'm not going to be dumb enough to try to speak for black people
here.
I wouldn't do that.
But I'll tell you what.
There was plenty of black people on that show speaking for white people and you
know,
I'm not saying there were 100% wrong,
but they will never speaking for all the sports fans out there who happened to
be white like me,
the whole trial.
When I was watching that,
I was never thinking,
oh,
that son of a bitch,
black guy killed that pure blonde white woman.
I never thought that shit.
The entire trial.
I've thought the exact same thing.
Anytime I would turn it on,
I would think the exact same thing.
I would be like,
Daddy's fucking Oj Simpson.
Oj Simpson is sitting behind that table on trial for a double murder.
I grew up watching that guy.
You know,
when he did the heart's commercials,
I was just,
I was like five or six years old and that old lady Gow Gow right when he would
fucking jump over the luggage.
I wasn't old enough to know that a black guy starring in a fucking commercial
like that was groundbreaking.
I didn't,
I just knew that that guy was fucking awesome.
He had a cool nickname.
My first pack of football cards,
I got Cleo for the love of fucking Christ.
Can you lay down buddy?
All right.
Get up here.
Get up here and there you go.
Lay down.
So yeah,
given I give it a go,
just show cubed.
Anyways,
back to Oj.
Um,
my first pack of football cards and it got,
he was right on top,
right on fucking top.
I think the gun was in the back so it didn't ruin it.
And,
um,
that was like my prize possession.
And I remember I was so young when he got traded to the 40 niners and I got that
tops football card that me and my brothers used to call side year because
everything was on when we used to trade.
Like what year?
Flag here,
side year,
football year.
Um,
rather than the years.
I thought it was gonna be worth money because he was on a different team.
Like,
wow,
this is Oj Simpson's on the 40.
Niners this is going to be worth money because people do,
you know,
I didn't realize that the rookie card,
I was young,
I was stupid.
And then I watched his fucking movies,
the naked gun.
I watched him on Monday night football when he was with Joe Nemeth and he would
be like,
you don't want to,
I would have done,
but I would have cut back.
He used to say what he would do.
And then Joe Nemeth would always say the same thing.
That was a really nice play play.
He's always say that shit.
And it was a terrible year for Monday night football or whatever.
I just remember hearing shit that Bob Costas and Al Michaels,
you know,
born in contact with them anymore.
There was the first time I really remember watching somebody have it all and
then fucking lose it all.
And it was always,
that's how I always looked at Oj Simpson's 2003 fucking yards in a season.
Heisman trophy winner,
star of the naked gun one and two and that fucking movie where he was the
astronaut,
right.
And the thing goes bad and then they try to kill him.
That's who the fuck he was in there.
He was just sitting there on track.
I couldn't fucking believe it.
So the next time they do one of those documentaries,
they got to have a dope like me in there.
Not going like you know it and the history and the justice system,
black thing will always say the lightbars again.
I'll play with it.
Tell me.
It was,
it was fucking,
it was Oj Simpson.
All right.
For you youngsters out there just about who,
who's your guy?
You know what I mean?
Is there even a guy like that anymore?
I don't know.
I can't relate to it anymore because every time I look at an athlete now it's
just somebody half my fucking age live in a dream that never happened to me.
Um,
this is fucking ridiculous.
All right.
Where the fuck are we?
Here?
Let me get to,
well,
let me get to some of the reads for the week here and then I go workout because
I go to the gym.
Um,
I maintain it guys.
I put on a few,
then I take it off,
put on a few,
we'll take it up and I'm still on my fight and fucking weight.
Um,
which I don't even know what the fuck it is.
Anyone,
which is good cause I got active mark tomorrow,
so maybe I'll look sexy and maybe I'll get some more work on it,
but I don't know where the fuck is.
Oh,
did I close the wrong one?
Ah,
is it,
could this be like a new segment on the fucking podcast where bill tries to find
the fucking window that he opened and everything was fine and he had it all set
up and then he fucks it up when he's on live.
All right.
Contents,
contents.
Hey,
if you guys want to email the podcast bill@themmpodcast.com.
All right.
Draft kings inside,
inside,
or explanation.
All right,
cause I didn't get a last week.
I don't understand why it was such a big fucking deal that some people from
draftkings one 300 grand at fan duel and they were saying that they had inside
information and sign.
I was like,
what are yeah,
what are your friends will or what are the way?
Have a friend little player though.
Um,
so bill not trying to be a container,
just explaining why that guy from draftkings,
what he did was considered insider information and made money.
Basically he had access to the percentage of ownership of the players.
For example,
he knew that 58% of people were starting Brady.
13% were starting.
Russell Wilson,
Wilson,
80% start,
uh,
starting Julio Jones,
et Cetera.
Obviously these are not the real percentage.
It's just an example.
While even if they were,
I wouldn't be able to figure out the math.
So thank you for giving me round numbers anyways.
He and all and uh,
only others at draftkings had that information.
Not anyone else.
The general meaning the general public,
um,
that we're playing in those games.
The numbers are released after the lineups are locked,
but he had them beforehand.
Okay.
So I understand that he had information,
but I don't understand what you do do with the information because I don't play
fantasy football or to this shit.
So hopefully you'll break it down a little more.
He and the uh,
um,
player percentage own is potentially the biggest factor when picking players.
Why this is,
why is this significant do please don't ask the questions.
Just fucking give me the answers.
Why?
I don't know.
Well,
the only way to actually make money and get ahead of other players is if you had
different people starting than them.
Right?
If 80% of the people are starting Julio Jones and you have him,
you won't get ahead of people,
you will be even with them.
Yeah.
But if Julio has a bigger day,
you're going to be fucked.
So what this country did was look at the players with the lowest percentage
owned that also had the highest potential law.
They have big Gabes he uses inside information he had at draftkings to play in
big money tournaments at fan duel.
Also,
he wanted big money almost every day playing MLB fantasy.
It's not out of the question to think he could have added information from
shark.
His buddies are the highest bidder.
Oh,
that's very interesting.
That's really fascinating.
That's going to be a great movie,
right?
Let's give you an animal is Facebook movies.
You know,
some awkward guys gonna play the awkward guy that started it.
No.
Cool.
Does anybody cool who's fucking,
you know,
can hold up their end of a conversation ever starting think he like a really
introverted thing.
This computer stuff,
it's amazing.
They can't talk to people yet.
What they make speaks to so many.
Wow.
Sorry.
Uh,
there must have been a collective that use on that one.
All right.
Nfl Pink.
Dear Billy Schram.
Uh,
if a guy likes Phil Sims,
Jim Nance or Chris Collins,
where spoke out about extortion involved in the breast cancer awareness pink
campaign,
would they lose their job?
Of course if they said it's stupid,
they just lose their job.
But if they articulated the problem with parading survivors on the field at the
beginning of the game,
like during the New England Dallas game,
a while only giving pennies on the dollar to the actual cause,
would they come under fire or be praised?
Thanks the guy.
I think I've answered all of those questions.
Um,
look,
I mean the NFL is always going to sell jerseys.
So they make some pink ones and the pink ones,
they give a percent evidently allegedly to a,
the cancer people,
uh,
the awareness people in,
then they give 8% of that 8% and I fucking works.
I mean it's better than not.
Yeah.
I mean,
I think the way they presented it,
like a portion of the proceeds fans,
all we hear is like,
Oh,
I buy this Jersey and then they give all this money.
You know,
I get a jersey,
it's not the color I wanted,
but that's going to help out people that are suffering.
Um,
so yeah,
it's not,
it's not the most transparent advertising gives a fuck.
Right.
They don't give a shit.
They didn't give a shit when ray rice fucking knocked out his fiance and he only
gave him two fucking games and they didn't give a fuck until the video came out.
Then they suspended him forever.
They didn't give a fuck.
Why can't,
because ray rice fucking was making him a bunch of money.
It's like,
you know,
they get,
they call it the Brady rule about not hitting low and hitting the quarterback
late.
It's not the Brady rule.
It's the fucking money rule.
They don't give a fuck about Tom Brady.
Tom Brady make some money and Tom Brady's not playing.
They lose money.
So they're like,
we got to protect that motherfucker.
Not because Tom has any sort of influence,
although he is pretty dreamy to look at a lifeguard bill.
I'm a lifeguard in a strong swimmer.
I was at the beach last week and I noticed the body go under.
Oh my God.
Oh my God,
Dude.
That's one of the scariest fucking,
that's one of my biggest fears in life.
The undertow was bad that day and I had a bad feeling so I swam to where I
thought someone went under.
I pulled up an 11 year old kid.
He had water in his lungs and was struggling through this better be true because
I or you better go into writing because I'm a riveted right now.
I didn't need to give him give full on CPR,
but I did have to administer the proper response to get them to cough out the
water.
He wasn't small and he wasn't being stupid.
That's just the way the ocean is.
The next day the newspaper tried to interview me.
I really didn't want to.
Every time someone does something and they're in the paper for it,
it feels like a celebration.
It's not someone could have died.
I understand that I may have done something great or you doing the aw shucks
thing is it's like a humble brag.
I've been told that I just don't want to celebrate.
The report has said that I was doing a disservice because I was presenting the
story from a being inspiring.
Do they need my soundbite?
Can't,
can't the story be enough?
Am I an asshole?
No,
you're not.
You're not an asshole at all.
Just fuck you.
Do what you do and then fuck them.
Fuck them.
Yeah.
Let them figure out what the fuck happened.
I don't think you are.
I don't think you're being an asshole at all.
Uh,
you know,
if you're telling the truth and you're actually actually being honest right now,
you didn't use your name so you're not going to get any praise.
I think what you're doing,
I think what you did was great.
Yeah.
I don't need to fucking talk to you.
I don't know if we supposed to talk around about,
talk about how fucking great you are.
I saw him go under and I knew if I didn't get out there,
if I didn't do something,
nobody would.
Um,
no,
I think,
you know,
especially this day and age,
when did you scratch sucking a dick?
Gets you a TV show?
You're actually saved somebody from drowning.
I mean,
probably get a fucking mini series
actually.
Is that better than a TV series?
Will most TV series don't get picked up?
I don't know.
Actually.
Just get a pilot is what you really good.
All right,
Bill,
he'd done.
Yeah,
I'm done.
All right.
My girlfriend wants to sell her panties online.
How do you not read this?
I know you guys.
I didn't give a shit if these are real enough.
These are very entertaining.
Hey,
Billy,
beef arts.
Uh,
I moved,
it meets my situation is exactly what it sounds like.
Last week,
my girlfriend of six years asked me if I think it's okay if she sells her used
panties online.
Gross to some of those Weirdo fetishes who enjoys that kind of shit.
I said,
sure.
Thinking what's the harm?
Well,
what if one of those guys is in those?
There's a forensic expert and that's also his fucking,
you know,
and that's how he kind of be going.
All those murder scenes.
He started sniffing panties.
Now he's afraid he's going to get caught.
So we ordered them online and then after a while the smells in enough.
So he starts dusting the panties for prints and next thing you know we standing
at your door with a fucking meat cleaver and a hard on and you went to the door.
You know he's got one hammer for one,
he's got the ax for the other and you show up.
That's going through your fucking head.
And then he's looked going and looking for your panty lists.
Girlfriend,
I think you fucking nuts.
Anyways,
I said,
sure.
They can watch the hub where both university students,
she needs money and what's the harm and milking these Wackos for old pantie
stain and clam juice.
Dude,
there's no way you love this woman.
Here's the problem.
She tells me that she needs to have pictures taken in these panties to PR to
prove to her potential clients that she did actually wear them.
Now she doesn't.
They want to smell them so they see her.
So they got a man fucking rob 'em out.
Um,
when she told me this,
I wasn't really,
it wasn't really in a way that was asking for permission.
Not that I would expect her to,
not that I would expect her to.
This is how much the these fucking American male has been beaten down.
Then if they don't let the woman in their life do every fucking thing that she,
every fucking fucking idea that comes to her head,
if they get in the way of it,
they're crushing or dream.
How about have you [inaudible] you're a fucking,
yeah,
you're not even her boyfriend at this point.
You're just an entourage member.
Just go,
hey,
where are we going tonight?
Well,
that's cool.
Can you be a fellow?
Could deal love this woman.
Don't fucking let her do this.
This is a dumb fucking idea.
Don't you have dumb ideas?
Doesn't she say to you every once in a while,
hey,
that's a stupid idea.
And then afterwards you're like,
Jesus Christ.
What was I thinking?
Thank God you were in my life.
This is when you need to step up,
not stand down.
She just,
Ah,
dude,
if she fucking does it,
she's basically,
she's in the porno industry.
Her picture's going to be online on a panty sniffer fucking website.
What?
What fucking job you get after that and it lives forever
and they'll wait.
They'll wait till she's running for office.
You know where she starts her own fucking campaign to stop some fucking disease.
Right.
Then that thing's going to come out.
The old patty panty sniffer fucking photo is going to come up anyways.
He says,
but more of of anyways.
Not that I would expect her to.
So what if?
What if?
So what have you dabbled into the porn industry?
However the,
fuck you,
we're going to do it but just a picture.
Huh?
I don't know.
It's fucking crazy.
Anyways,
but more of a,
this would be part of the deal kind of way.
She brought it up to up to me immediately.
I tell her that I have a huge problem with this.
Well,
all right then.
All right then you scared me there earlier and she should not be doing it.
She argues that and I quote,
I liked the attention it gets.
All right dude.
You know what?
This is the sound of
that is the sound of you backing up the dump truck that she's laying in the back
of and dumping that bitch in the trash.
Dude,
this is not the mother.
Your kids this God bless her.
I don't know who the fuck fuck they've her up.
It's,
it's all over
out.
It's over dude.
It's out and it's done.
I don't even need to read the rest of this.
He goes like,
what the fuck am I supposed to do here?
That's why he is voted to keep my mouth shut and act like a cuckold or f or
fight this thing to the bitter end.
I know it's her body and she has the right to do anything with it.
Shut the fuck up with that.
Jesus Christ.
He's fucking feminist.
You guys have turned into zombies.
This is it like a date rape situation.
I get,
she does have the right to do it,
but you,
you stopping him from getting into the porn industry,
but it makes me feel like a complete tool.
It should.
Any input would be appreciated.
Bill,
I think I told you,
I think I told you what you should do to just,
yeah,
you know what?
This is the deal.
Okay?
Even if she goes,
you're good.
Break out with it or that.
Forget it.
I won't do it.
I can't live without you.
Fuck that.
Whatever.
This is this.
This is a,
this is going to rear its ugly fucking head again.
I liked the attention it gets.
She likes that kind of attention.
Okay?
I'm telling you right now,
dude,
somebody that likes that kind of fucking of attention,
if not the attention that she can get within a fucking one-on-one monogamy
monogamous relationship.
All right?
Now whether she'll ever act on it and go even further,
end up on a pole,
a blowing somebody behind a dumpster,
down at a Denny's after she ate some bad scrambled eggs.
Who's the fucking know?
All you know is that you're rolling the dice with half of your shit.
If you ever marry this kid,
this kid,
this woman,
and have kids,
you know,
and the kids are going to have to play fucking look like her.
Oh Dude.
I'm just flying down the road with this thing dumper dude dumper.
That's a deal breaker.
I'm sorry.
That's a fucking deal breaker.
Done over.
All right.
Just be like,
listen,
uh,
we've come to a fork in the road and a,
you want to be a model for a panty sniffing website,
which I totally respect and uh,
I would like to be with somebody that I can trust,
you know,
who doesn't need the attention of some of the fucking weirdest people on the
Internet.
Okay,
good luck.
And thank you for playing.
Now have you guys ever listened to the uh,
yeah,
the all things comedy podcasts that I've done,
I do live with the Al Madrigal.
You have listened to those Al Madrigal.
Okay.
Is it very busy man?
So he might not have time to give you breakup advice.
Al Madrigal.
It has the greatest way how you break up with a woman that you,
if you're not living with this woman,
the greatest way ever,
and I'm giving him full credit here and he's already told the story on a
podcast,
so I don't feel like I'm overstepping my bounds here.
This is the greatest way ever.
This is what he would do.
When he did knew that he was going to break up with a woman and uh,
women can do this too.
He would,
and the,
the woman was not living with him.
He would gather up all of her shit that was in the apartment and he would put it
in a box.
He called her up,
said,
I need to come over there and talk to you.
He'd come over with the box teller,
it was over and then he would fucking leave.
And then there was nothing else.
There was no reason for her to come back.
And that was it.
That's what you need to do with her and you need to pack up all her paintings
that she's going to be selling in modeling soon so she can become a fucking off
model.
Okay.
And she's free to do that because it's her body snap 12 to six,
right?
Is that what they do?
That's her fucking body.
It's her.
Right?
She's an independent woman.
Beyonce.
The whole fucking thing.
Feminism.
Yeah.
I'm doing this shit.
Have fun,
sweetheart.
Right?
She's going to go become a jerk off model and if you stay with her,
you will become a jerk off.
And you don't want to do that because eventually it's going to breed resentment
and uh,
you know,
dude,
like yeah,
it's going to be over.
You can't marry her.
You get fucking married.
It's done.
It's fucking over.
It's going to get out.
Then your neighbor's going to find out.
Then your neighbors are going to be jerking off to her and then you got to get a
nickname.
You know it's fucking over.
God help you if your name starts with p.
All right,
Peter,
Paul,
any of that shit that,
the alliteration with Pannie.
I Dunno what the fuck is going to be,
but you're,
it's,
it's going to be a fucking nightmare.
Jerk off,
Jerry.
I don't know what the fuck is going to be,
but to do you need to get out,
right?
Bp Dump
that bitch and the fucking trash over.
Over.
So is this podcast all right.
Go fuck yourselves.
We'll talk to you on Thursday.